euh alors Chantal
voici mon stagiaire même l'été Tom villa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'aime les filles les magazines
comment ça va ça va bien tout va bien
c'est pas moi qui a décidé de la tenue
en tout cas vraiment Thierry je vous en
veux parce que ça commence comme ça et
ça finit avec des nouilles dans le slip
magnifique plateau Thierry que des
femmes et c'est pas la journée de la
femme bravo
[Applaudissements]
si le Paradis ressemble au plateau de ce
soir je suis prêt à y aller et si c'est
l'enfer aussi vraiment
[Applaudissements]
Daphné Bürki c'est le qui a réussi à
percer en télé avec une voix aussi
agaçante que celle de Ségolène Royal et
bravo
voilà du coup vous devez connaître hyper
bien l'égérie comment Rachida Dati et
vous avez bossé aux côtés de John
Galliano
de designer des Buffon SS et donc
vous êtes toujours en contact avec lui
vous avez fait une croix gammée sur lui
on a coupé les ponts en tout cas
aujourd'hui voilà vous êtes à la télé
vous aviez présenté les Maternelles sur
France 5 et d'ailleurs il faut aussi
Karine et une fois dans les maternelles
Daphné vous aviez invité Carla Bruni
pour qu'il vienne vous parler de son
périnée voilà comme dit Thierry elle a
dû mettre moins de temps à rééduquer son
périnée que son mari mais
et puis je le sais de source secrète il
y a peut-être une envie peut-être de
monter sur scène je sais Karine ça vous
travaillez aussi le one woman show alors
Chantal
ça vous dit de présenter L'Amour est
dans le pré ou pas absolument
pécore il trouvait une gonzesse ou pas
[Applaudissements]
chantal Ladesou on l'adore voilà vous
avez été l'une des premières à avoir
prouver qu'on pouvait être une femme et
drôle tout en le faisant exprès bravo et
non c'est vrai
et vous avez débuté dans l'émission la
classe sur François alors pour tous ceux
qui étaient pas né c'est l'équivalent un
peu du Jamel Comedy Club mais sans noir
ni arabe
allez rapide
et puis Chantal vous avez aussi débuté
dans dans Maggie contrairement à tous
les autres comédiens qui eux ont fini
dans Maggie est-ce que ce que j'adore
chez Chantal joue le lit Thierry c'est
qu'elle a une puissance comique dans la
voiture
rigolent et en plus vous êtes originaire
du Nord-Pas-de-Calais du coup ça vous
fait deux points communs avec Franck
Ribéry voilà
[Applaudissements]
Karine Le Marchand alors Karine comme
comme Daphné vous avez gardé le nom de
famille de votre ex compagnon vous
imaginez si tout le monde faisait ça
Carla Bruni ça s'appellerait Carla
Jagger Bertignac Clapton Peres Goldman
fabule San to and Sarkozy
[Applaudissements]
vous faites partie de l'équipe des
grosses têtes sur RTL alors les
grossesses c'est pas évident parce que
bah surtout en tant que femme et noir du
coup il y a quand même deux blagues sur
trois qui vous font pas rien et encore
vous auriez pu être juive donc j'ai du
sang juifs
[Applaudissements]
bon en tout cas Karine Le Marchand c'est
évidemment L'Amour est dans le pré et si
l'amour est dans le pré les
préliminaires sont dans la grange
et puis il y a votre nouvelle émission
qui arrive c'est des portraits de
personnalités politiques d'ailleurs
c'est quoi le titre l'avenir est dans le
pré l'amour est dans l'urne non c'est
une ambition intime
alors attendez attendez juste si je peux
le permettre c'est un très joli kit mais
c'est diffusé sur M6 si c'est diffusé le
dimanche soir après minuit j'ai peur
qu'il y ait des déçus voilà ou qu'il y
en a qui se caresse sur Alain Juppé ça
c'est quand même
[Applaudissements]
mesdames ici pour vous poser les
questions trop con que Thierry Ardisson
n'a pas voulu vous poser
ok Daphné Bürki Daphné c'est ça cause
des polémiques que vous avez opté pour
Burky et pas pour burqa
Karine Le Marchand votre meilleur ami
c'est Stéphane Plaza qu'est-ce qui vous
a séduit chez lui que lui au moins il
parle pas des femmes comme des voitures
mais comme des appartements une belle
hauteur sous plafond avec une grande
cheminée
oui il y a les poutres la poutre
apparente assez souvent
et pour terminer Chantal là-dessous
voilà c'est vrai que à l'époque votre
mari vous avez dragué en vous demandant
il y a quoi là dessous
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu